This trailer is rated ‘R’ for Robocop.
Cause that’s how you make a f*cking Robocop
movie!
It’s been more than 20 years since Robocop
appeared on the big screen, and now he’s
back, with a flip-up visor,
different origin,
a human hand,
and a PG-13 rating?
Screw that.
Instead, revisit the original masterpiece
that is...
Robocop.
Journey to a futuristic Detroit that’s become
a bankrupt crimeridden hellhole.
Basically present day Detroit.
It’s a city crying out for a savior, and
they’ll get one in Robocop, a blatant Jesus
metaphor who’s killed,
gets resurrected,
and walks on water.
But instead of dying for our sins, this Jesus
shoots rapists in the d*ck.
Meet his gum-chewing partner Lewis, a terrible
cop who never waits for backup,
runs like a girl,
and can’t resist male nudity.
"Mind if I... zip this up?"
Baaaaaalls.
Together, they’ll take down Old Detroit’s
biggest bad guys:
Clarence Boddicker, a drug lord who’s got
a real way with the ladies,
"Maybe you could, uh, fit me in."
Omni Consumer Products, an evil corporation
that does everything except make consumer
products,
ED-209, a heavily armed killing machine who
loses to a flight of stairs.
And glass.
Robo-suit up for the ultimate awesome 80’s
movie, full of...
big hair,
cocaine,
goons,
Cold War paranoia,
and a no-nonsense black police captain.
"Now get out of my police station and take
laughing boy with you!"
So return to a time when action movies were
made for adults but marketed to children.
Featuring some of film’s best one liners...
“Dead or alive, you’re coming with me.”
“Your move, creep.”
“I’d buy that for a dollar!”
"B*tches leave."
And the Most.
Blood squibs.
Ever.
Guarantee you won’t see THAT in the remake.
Starring...
Daft Punk
Bruce Jenner
Tough Lady Cop
Old 80’s Businessman
Even Older 80’s Businessman
Jordan Belfort
That 70’s Drug Lord
Fox News
and Lindsay Lohan.
Robocop.
Robocop is the last movie that needs a freakin
remake.
What are they gonna reboot next, Die Hard?
Oh no! I’ve said too much!
Hey, Screen Junkies. For more awesome stuff,
click here to subscribe.